à votre avis de quoi va-t-on parler
aujourd'hui je vous donne dans le mille
regarder tout est là je le pose y en a
on va se concentrer
on va parler aujourd'hui de ce truc là
salah ce casque alors je le sais
effectivement dans le titre je vous
parle d'apple parce que vite parce que
apple mélange tout parce qu'apple a
racheté but beats et la marque été créée
par dr dre et apple effectivement
racheté cette marque il ya quelques
années et line propose un modèle qui est
vraiment intéressant je crois je crois
en tout cas pour moi c'est le meilleur
casque café blitz de tous les temps pour
plusieurs raisons je vous détailler
c'est ce casque là c'est le sol en pro
de beats il vous le disais si mormeck
ils ont travaillé avec pharrell williams
sur ce casque l'a priori c'est ce que
j'ai cru comprendre et se casse que là
il est vraiment intéressant
il propose plein de choses cool et
surtout me comble un point négatif qu
avec beats depuis de nombreuses années
c'est la qualité audio alors attention
attention attention je sais ça dépend il
y en a qui aimait leçon beats moi
personnellement je n'avais pas trop
grave
tout reste est un petit peu perdu
c'était pas terrible si vous écoutiez du
gros et reading voulu que ça ronronne
grave vous aviez le sont ce qu'ils
voulaient un son avec beaucoup de
présence en bas moteur du lourd hockey
si vous aimez profiter de la qualité
audio qui a été fait au mixage et au
mastering et bien vous la perdiez
simplement parce que les casques était
beaucoup trop typé et avec ça
croyez moi ils ont vraiment changé leur
fusil d'épaulé en vous proposant un
produit qui est quand même beaucoup
mieux réussi mes ventes par les beats et
c'est moi vous inviter à venir à vous
abonner à la chaîne ne s'est pas déjà le
cas pour tous suivent de l'actuelle a
plein de choses à dire quelque chose à
faire je teste pas un truc des
smartphones et des casques des
ordinateurs je parle de teck
donc si c'est pas déjà le cas je
l'invité à vous abonner bien évidemment
à l'essai des jolies pouce en bas de
cette vidéo pour permettre à cette vidéo
de bien se référencer voilà les
objectifs principaux
maintenant on va parler de ça et
regarder on va comparer avec un autre
casque générations précédentes et je
vais vous montrer ce que j'aime ce que
j'aime pas ce qui est bien et ce qui
n'est pas bien laissez-moi commencer par
commencement on se concentre sur cette
boîte là c'est la boîte justement du 1er
août on a parlé aujourd'hui cette boîte
lie plutôt cool je vais pas vous faire
faire le tour de la boîte aujourd'hui on
s'en fiche de cette boîte là elle montre
un truc est vachement intéressant c'est
ça active noise cancelling avec mon très
bel accent ça veut dire que ce cas ce
que là en l'occurrence celui là non pas
cela allez vous en vous ce cas ce que là
il a une réduction bruit active et ça
c'est cool parce que sur la génération
précédente
eh bien vous ne l'aviez pas
ce casque là il permet de faire plein de
choses que vous ne pouviez pas faire
avant parce que aujourd'hui vous avez le
solo pro alors qu'avant vous aviez le
solo 3 wireless sans fil avec le solo
pro on a de la réduction de bruit active
le fameux hervé à fameux malgré l'écrire
vous en fichez ici vous ne l'avez pas
avec le solo pro vous avez de la
recharge grâce au port lightning ici si
le micro usb
c'est quand même beaucoup moins sexy
prière des vous les avez là pour
lightning micro usb
le solo promet un truc qui est super
cool c'est que pour vous dire est allumé
eh bien vous avez qu'à l'ouvrir comme ça
tandis que l'autre eh bien vous avez un
petit bouton on off qui est situé juste
ici et c'est un petit peu moins sexy
vous avez donc une ouverture fermeture
qui vous permet il ya vu un mec tandis
que de l'autre côté
eh bien vous avez un bouton mais surtout
le gros point positif du solo pro c'est
la qualité audio qui est vraiment bien
meilleur que ce que vous allez trouver
de l'autre côté parce que de l'autre
côté vous avez quoi vous avez des basses
des basses des basses et des basses
alors maintenant le solo pro il est pas
mal n'y a pas que des points positifs il
n'a absolument pas de prise jack de
prise jack 3.5 il n'en a pas ça c'est
vraiment dommage tandis que lui il à ce
point jack avec lui et ça c'est vraiment
cool
autre point que solo pro n'a pas et que
l'autre cas ce cas c'est un petit voyant
de batterie vous voyez exactement le
niveau qui vont être enfin quelque chose
près vous le devinez ça c'est bien
tandis que sur le solo pro bien voyez
vous n'avez absolument aucun voyant vous
mettre uniquement sans le smartphone
pour regarder ça c'est un peu dommage
bon après y'a un petit changement mineur
dire qu'ici vous avez les boutons
boutons pour mettre plein vol décrocher
raccrocher un appel vous montez son goût
baisse elles sont deux fois morceau
suivant trois fois morceaux précédents
vous l'avez là c'est à droite n'excuse
en l'autre c'est à gauche c'est
sensiblement le même principe pour les
ouvrir pour les fermer c'est pareil pour
les sensiblement sur la maine expérience
ça marche je préfère l'arceau du nouveau
la voyez vous à l'espace d'art sont en
métal en tout 40 fosses à un peu moins
sympa ici vous avez un arceau qui a
intérieur qui est un peu plus doux vous
réglez vraiment plus comme vous voulez
vous avez pas cette sensation de cran
parce que vous n'en avez pas tout
simplement
donc c'est un peu plus qu'ali là à
l'intérieur on a un rembourrage il va
mettre beaucoup plus agréable puisque là
on a un rembourrage up caoutchouc 14 ans
un petit peu tiré sur les cheveux
toujours de la mousse à mémoire de forme
tout être un peu plus épaisse sur le
modèle professionnel
bon c'est du point de détail et on a un
modèle qui
légèrement plus grand j'ai l'impression
sur le modèle pro que sur le modèle 3 ça
paraît quand même normal que sur le
modèle professionnel vous aviez plus
d'options pour faire plus de choses que
ce que vous avez sur l'autre modèle en
fait le sol au procès une évolution du
solo 3 wireless et c'est une vraie belle
évolution
au delà du quota plus caoutchouc du côté
un peu confort et la vrai changement va
se faire au niveau de l'audio je vous
l'expliquais dans quelques instants par
contre un truc je suis un peu moins
moyen fans c'est la qualité du casque
alors lorsque vous le mettez comme ça
déjà éteint vous avez une réduction de
bruit passif parce que ça vient boucher
vos oreilles ici c'est un casque supra
auriculaires terre 5 à ce qui vient se
poser sur vos oreilles mais par contre
il ya un petit effet de pinces qui vient
vraiment coincé vous bloquez les
oreilles alors ce qui est plutôt bien
acceptée pas c'est qu'effectivement déjà
vous avez une isolation sonore un peu
passive de l'extérieur ça on retrouvait
sur le solo trois voyants laisse donc
déjà voyez comme ça ça vient peut vous
coupé de l'extérieur mais ce que je fais
sur lui en plus c'est de rajouter de la
réduction de bruit active
vous avez des micros qui capte le son
ambiant qui vient l'annuler c'est avec
ça vous coupe de l'extérieur alors je
vais vous expliquer ça dans quelques
instants c'est vachement bien vous avez
différents modes je vous le détail
moyens fait par contre que j'aime
moyennement bien on est quand même sans
casque écoute contre l'asthme 299,95 ce
qui n'est pas le plus petit prix du
marché on est quand même dans le haut de
gamme dans le haut du panier
dans cette hypothèse il produit et je
veux toujours regretter malgré tout
malgré tous ces points positifs le
confort un peu sur les oreilles lorsque
vous être notre position ce qui se
trouve assez rapidement eh bien voyez il
vient un peu compressé vos oreilles
alors après ça dépend de la morphologie
de chacun ça dépend les oreilles et
chacun mais vous n'allez pas tenir des
heures et des heures et des heures comme
ça avec ce casque est là et c'est
vraiment ce que j'ai vu reprocher ce cas
cela parce que si vous voulez profiter
pour moi du meilleur confort et de la
meilleure expérience ses beats c'est ce
qu'à ce que là ça c'est le modèle studio
et le modèle studio il vient englober
vos oreilles voyez il ya une vraie
grosse différence c'est pas si vous en
rendrez compte m'en fait celui là il
vient autour de vos oreilles il vient
vraiment prendre tout beau tout rose or
qu'est-ce que ça ils vont se reposer sur
vos oreilles on n'a pas du tout la même
sensation et lorsque vous écoutez
pendant des heures et des heures et des
heures de la musique
et bien croyez moi ça change quand même
beaucoup de choses là il ya une vraie
sensation de confort avec le modèle
studio tandis qu'avec les modèles solo
même avec le solo pro x bloc
récemment les autres et bien cette
sensation voyez vous n'avez pas la même
ça vient se poser sur les oreilles alors
on est dans le haut du panier par
rapport à ce que sait faire bits
là dessus ça reste quand même un
excellent casque on a plein de jolies
casse mais par contre là où beats
excellent c'est vraiment en terme
d'expérience audio et ben oui parce que
à quoi sert un casque c'est pas vous
proposer une excellente expérience audio
le but d'un casque c'est d'écouter des
choses
écouter de la musique regarder des films
regardés des concerts ce que vous voulez
c'est d'écouter ses expérience audio
alors bien évidemment tout ce qui va
être réduction de bruit tout ce qui va
être confort ça fait partie je dirais de
l'ensemble mais le principal l'essence
même de casse ça reste l'audio voilà
quoi on parle ça c'est votre spectre
audio
vous allez avoir ici toutes les
fréquences infra l'on va se dire jusqu'à
100 hertz là je vous parle anvers
on va arriver ici vers un kilo c'est à
dire mille hertz on va avoir ensuite
tout ce qui va être médium et du vert
1,5 kg et après vous arrivés vers 10 kg
et même carrément 15 16 kg bon voila
vous ce que vous allez entendre au
niveau de vos voix on va dire que tout
ce qui va ressortir au niveau de la voix
va se trouver à peu près ici la
fréquence que vous attendez lorsque vous
passez un coup de téléphone
ça va surtout se situer voyez ici aux
alentours de 1 kg 1 kg vous avez le
fameux de 2.5 kg tout ce qui va être
sont un petit peu si bilan et les
aiguilles qui vont être aux alentours de
5 6 kg qui situe par ici donc voyez un
petit peu ça c'est votre spectre audio
donc une voie ça se situe pas là lorsque
vous écoutez de la musique tout ce qui
va être cymbales ça situe par là lorsque
vous écoutez des choses très graves vous
écoutez une basse ça va situer pas ici
ça dépend comment c'est réglé ça dépend
du village se défend pas mal de choses
lorsque vous avez un casque qui propose
une meilleure expérience audio vous avez
un son qui est flat c'est à dire que la
qualité audio et lamelles quelles que
soient les fréquences qui va faire
moduler ses vous avec votre équaliseur
vous pouvez le voir et bien monter un
petit peu les médiums les élus vous
m'aiderez les comme vous voulez mais la
qualité audio est complètement plate par
contre ce qui est tendance un petit peu
à faire vite c'est d'avoir une courbe un
peu comme ça voyez vous aviez un saut
qui était vraiment boosté chez boostedge
est boosté ici beaucoup trop de basse
alors c'était extrêmement flatteur pour
tout ce que vous allez avoir en terme de
musique hip hop musique électro
compagnie c'est très très très très
flatteur par contre ça dénature
extrêmement la musique tous les sons
médiums aigus les sons aigus vous
perdiez un petit peu en précision au
profit d'un sont beaucoup trop grave
beaucoup trop basse et ça c'était
vraiment dommage ça c'était donc sans
compter sur l'arrivée de ce fameux
casque beats
solo pro qui vient remettre un petit peu
tout à niveau est un peu tout plat et je
trouve ça vraiment bien parce que on se
réapproprie vraiment la musique parce
qu'on peut vraiment redécouvrir la
musique différemment au travers d'un
casque beats et ça croyez moi c'est
vraiment bien et c'est pour moi un des
points essentiels et un point
extrêmement important lorsqu'on vient
écouter de la musique moi j'adore
écouter de la musique j'écoute beaucoup
de musique dans différents moments de ma
vie dans différents moments de la
journée et notamment lorsque je voyage
j'aime beaucoup
lorsque je voyage à bord un casque sur
les oreilles je me prend fin des vieux
je m'évade et lorsque j'écoute avec un
casque qui va beaucoup trop venir un
voile à toi qui viens trop flatter les
graves et ben je suis pas satisfait je
n'aime pas ça du coup je suis vraiment
content que ce cas ce que la permettent
de retrouver l'essence même de ce à quoi
sert un casque c'est à dire écouter de
la musique et le flair sans fioritures
tout simplement plat alors ça c'est bien
mais c'est pas parfait
pourquoi tout simplement parce qu'il me
manque un petit quelque chose il me
manque
le fait de pouvoir venir régler les
équaliseur alors je peux régler
équaliseur lorsque je suis sur mon
iphone dans mon application de musique
dédié mon iphone l'âge peut
effectivement venir le faire mais
lorsque j'écoute de la musique sur une
application tierce ce soit spotify lui
compagnie eh bien je ne peux pas le
faire et je trouve ça quand même
relativement dommage enfin que ce que
j'aurais vraiment aimé c'est que ben x
me propose une application dédiée que je
puisse utiliser il soit sur ios mais
également sur android pour pouvoir venir
paramétrer mon casque comme je souhaite
et même pourquoi pas créer des scènes en
fonction des utilisateurs c'est par
exemple je vais le prêter à quelqu'un
d'autre qui va écouter de la musique à
travers mon iphone mon envie nous peu
importe
et bien que je puisse le faire là sans
vraiment pousser l'expérience plus loin
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui est
dans les tuyaux est ce que c'est un
projet wind en tout cas c'est vraiment
que j'aurais souhaité par contre que
j'adore vraiment être ce casque c'est le
mode d'ouverture et il ya connu
directement ici dans votre iphone est ce
qu'on est très très très très facilement
et moi je trouve ça vraiment vraiment
cool je trouve que ça rapporte vraiment
à l'expérience globale ça donne un petit
côté technologique ok on n'a plus besoin
de boutons
en gros ce que vous faites c'est que
lorsque vous avez terminé vous le plier
vous le mettez dans son petit étui qui
est juste là qui est très douce et à
côté un petit peu chaussettes vous
voulez et glisser dedans vous refermez
et ça c'est pratique et lorsque vous
venez sortir votre casque vous l'ouvrez
il s'active il se connecte
automatiquement et directement à votre
device donc ça c'est cool donc ça c'est
bien mais par contre un truc que je veux
ni regretter et que je trouve un peu
dommage sur ce produit là c'est que
j'adore ce côté un petit peu chaussettes
7 et 8 qui revient de protéger un peu
contre la poussière n'est par contre
absolument pas contre les coups se
regarder c'est un truc un peu ma classe
et ça bien se déformer on n'est pas dans
ce que nous proposait ce que peut lui
proposer de beats sur un modèle studio
qui lui me paraît être un peu plus
résistant sur le solo 3 on a une petite
housse qui pareille peut effectivement
venir s'abîmer le toucher est quand même
plus premium plus qu'ali plus agréable
j'aurais espéré d'un petit peu plus
résistant qui me rassurer et qui
viendrait davantage protéger mon casque
lorsque je la met dans un sac ou que ça
j'ai encore par contient un point qui
est très bon ici c'est l'autonomie
vous avez plus de 20 heures de musique
d'écouté que vous soyez sur le mode de
réduction bruit active ou sur le mode
transparence je vous expliquais dans
quelques instants
et même jusqu'à 40 heures lorsque vous à
les désactiver que ce soit le mode de
réduction brute actifs ou ce soit le
mode transparence ce qui fait que là
dessus
vous avez une énorme autonomie peut
profiter de la musique très longtemps
d'autant plus que 120 cas ce que vous
aller recharger très rapidement lorsque
vous avez besoin lorsque vous avez très
peu de temps devant vous en dix minutes
vous les mettez trois ans de chars
ça me paraît assez bien maintenant est
ce que vous allez supporter ce cas ce
que là pendant 20 heures sur vos
oreilles comme ça ça c'est la vraie
question mois le produit en lui même je
trouve assez rassurant vous êtes sur un
petit pivot ici pour venir vraiment
prouvé le confort que vous souhaitez bon
au delà du côté un peu et ses pinceaux
dans votre tête
ça c'est quand même plutôt pas mal cela
assez bien le fait que vous puissiez
venir l'agrandir le fermer aussi cette
manière là ça marche bien ça va vraiment
venir se régler à toutes les têtes les
boutons sur le côté sont très faciles à
manipuler seule chose que je vis
reproché ici c'est que ça on l'entend
quand même et le même lorsque vous avez
le cap sur votre tête avec la réduction
proactive et vous entendez le bruit du
bouton et ça c'est quand même un peu
moyen je vous laisse écouter qui
smartphone apple dit forcément syrie et
vous avez la commande vocale pouvait
donc appelé syrie directement si vous
utilisez à s'entendre android vous
pouvez utiliser le petit bouton ici pour
me rappeler votre google assistant tout
ça c'est bien mais un des points
importants et des apports majeurs sur ce
cas cela c'est la réduction de bruit
active le fait que vous ayez plusieurs
micros qui vont capter le son extérieur
et qui par un système de hors phases
vont venir annulé le son provenant de
l'extérieur qu'on veut nous enfermer
dans votre vue ça c'est cool lorsque
vous voyagez en train dans un avion
lorsque vous êtes dans des transports en
commun le métro le bus que vous marchez
dans la rue que vous ne voulez pas
écouter le monde autour de vous et bien
ça c'est vraiment cool en gros vous
explique vous avez donc demain le mode
de réduction brute actifs
ça c'est simple c'est ce que moi
j'utilise
défaut vous prenez votre carte vous
mettez ça vient vous coupé de
l'extérieur vous n'entendez plus du tout
les sons extérieurs
ensuite vous avez notre mode qui
s'appelle le vote transparence vous
pouvez l'activer et le désactiver on
appuie sur le petit bouton tac ici en
fait ce que ça va faire notre
transparence c'est que les micros que
vous avez autour du 4 vont injecter le
son extérieur dans le casque ça me
permet de bien entendre tout ce qui est
autour de moi par exemple je marche dans
la rue je vais traverser
j'entends les véhicules qui arrivent
j'entends un bus j'entends une voiture
j'entends les piétons j'entends ce qui
fait que ça permet d'être vraiment
éveillé par rapport à tous nos
environnements et maintenant il ya un
troisième mode c'est le mode qui permet
de désactiver que ce soit le mode
transparence où que ce soit le mode de
réduction bruit active je laisse appuyé
longtemps ici ça me désactive toulemon
en rouge me retrouve avec ce que j'ai
ici c'est à dire un casque qui vient
bloquer un peu supérieures grâce à une
réduction de bruit actif parce que sa
bouche les oreilles mais par contre
grâce à ça c'est pouvoir gagner en
autonomie
et c'est justement là que ce prêt à
monter jusqu'à 40 ans d'autonomie alors
écouter de la musique c'est cool mais
passer des appels avec son casque c'est
aussi un visage très intéressant et
justement ça marche plutôt bien
la qualité est là la qualité est au
rendez vous que ce soit pour la personne
qui vous 4 à l'autre bout du fil qui si
on peut encore parler de fait
aujourd'hui où que ce soit vous qui
allez parler et écouter vos
interlocuteurs et tout ça marche très
bien grâce à la puce h12 apple et grâce
au bluetooth classe 1 sans fil ce casque
offre donc une belle avancée par rapport
à ce que faisait beats avant et ça peut
venir convertir des gens comme moi qui
n'étais pas particulièrement convaincu
j'aimais bien ce projet la solution
intéressante mais j'allais pas acheter
un casque beats je me sentais pas client
bit parce que je n'ai pas le son la
leçon je trouve cool
la spatialisation est aussi excellente
il n'y a pas une très grosse latence
pour regarder des films regarder des
vidéos sur youtube regarder la chaîne de
monsieur greu sans avoir un décalage
c'est pas le cas ce que le plus léger du
haut de ses 2 167 g mais si je dois
venir comparé par rapport à ce que
j'avais avant le solo 3 wireless
eh bien voyez je trouve que le confort
est quand même beaucoup moins bons aussi
la qualité audio est quand même beaucoup
moins bonne c'est bien meilleures ici
par contre si ça doit venir comparer
avec le studio qui lui offre la
meilleure expérience de confort moi ce
que je voudrais c'est un hybride je
voudrais le confort du studio et je
voudrais la qualité audio du solo pro et
là je pense qu'on aurait le casque
ultime
chez beez parce que je vais vraiment
venir regretté sur ce modèle là qui
n'est pas deux prises jack par exemple
je sais pas vous prenez l'avion
moi je prends souvent l'avion vous
prenez l'avion vous décidez de brancher
votre casque grâce à deux prises jack
directement dans votre solution de votre
ailleurs on pourra écouter vos films eh
bien vous ne pouvez pas c'est
strictement impossible
vous n'avez pas de prise jack et il n'ya
pas d'adaptateur fourni lightning vers
prise jack de mai la même manière
lorsque je veux faire un vol de onze
heures par exemple pour aller je sais
pas clairement à san francisco eh bien
je ne vois pas passer 11 heures avec le
casque sur les oreilles parce qu'au bout
d'un moment je vais pas le supporter le
fait qu'on entende les boutons lorsque
vous allez venir appuyer ça c'est aussi
assez moyen le fait que vous ne voyez
pas votre niveau de batterie si ce n'est
au travers de smartphones je trouve ça
aussi un petit peu dommage
le fait qu'ils aient pas d'écho à l'isr
assez dommage pour un casque a quasiment
300 euros voyez c'est plein de petits
détails qui mis bout à bout font que ce
cas cela est vraiment bien c'est une
super promesse un très bon casse mais il
n'est pas encore complètement optimale
par rapport à son positionnement
tarifaire par rapport à ce que peut
trouver à la concurrence c'est une vraie
belle progression pour beats ou que
c'est vraiment casque qui est vraiment
super en trouvant un peu moins cher
salle positionnerait beaucoup mieux
c'est un très bon gars c'est vraiment
excellent caste il ya encore quelques
petits points qui sont un peu bloquant
et qui je l'espère vont être rapidement
réglés sur une prochaine version parce
que la promesse qui est fait par bit si
vous allez sur leur site web jouer noté
là c'est la réduction proactive pour moi
ils ont franchement réussi là dessus
avec le solo pro la reine sombre et
active elle marche très bien
c'est un son puissant équilibré pour moi
ça marche aussi
et un confort optimal là pour moi ils ne
tiennent pas pour moi que ça fait partie
des trois promesses qui sont annoncés en
tout premier sur la page produit sur le
site de beats et bien voyez y en a neuf
soutenu la troisième est beaucoup moins
bonnes a vous de me dire maintenant ce
que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous avez un casque de byd si
oui lequel alors il ya plein de couleurs
il n'y a pas que cette couleur là il ya
du rouget du crème il ya du blanc il ya
du grief il ya plein de choses
moi j'ai des prix en bleu j'aime bien le
bleu ça ressemblait sans la chaîne c'est
joli dites moi ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous avez un casque beats est
ce que vous n'avez pas trop comme moi le
fait que les casques beats d'ancienne
génération ou génération précédente
regarde ça comme ça ramène beaucoup trop
de g et est-ce qu'un casque comme
celui-là comme le solo prend pourrez
vous tentez dans la mesure effectivement
on a un son qui quand même beaucoup
mieux maîtriser très équilibré est
vraiment cool avec une réduction de
bruit active
mark et moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire j'invite bien évidemment à
vous abonner à blesser des geôles époux
sam envoyait beaucoup d'impôts
l'amour n'a eu beaucoup de loeb beaucoup
d'amour ça fait longtemps qu'on sait pas
fait la bise n'y a pas la toile à
l'aller en soin de toi soit sa hache et
puis on se retrouve demain
voilà c'est pas mal à demain demain
après demain là je pars à new york c'est
un peu compliqué dès fois que le
décalage horaire le temps d'arriver je
vais peut-être publié un jour sont de
fait on va voir donc si je suis pas là
demain m'en voulez pas pour tout cas je
serai là prennent me voilà avec deux
mois
[Musique]